in this video we're going to think about
how trade affects the total economic
surplus in a market and we're also going
to think about tariffs which are a per
unit charge that a government will often
put on some type of good that is being
imported usually to protect a domestic
industry but sometimes it's also to
raise revenue so right over here we have
a simple model for the sugar market in
some country and we're originally
initially going to assume that this
country is operating in isolation so
this is the supply curve for the
suppliers of sugar in that country and
then this is the demand curve for the
people who would want to use sugar in
that country and you can see the
equilibrium price and quantity in that
country now in this world we've reviewed
this in many videos what's the total
economic surplus well the total economic
surplus would be defined by this
triangle right over here it's the area
above the supply curve and below the
demand curve and we know that the part
above this horizontal line at the price
of 3 this would be the consumer surplus
and then down here this would be the
producer surplus now let's say that this
market opens up to the world to the
world price and let's say when it does
so it does not affect the world price
itself the world market is so large and
let's say this country's market is
relatively small and so the world market
let's say that sugar is trading at a
dollar fifty per pound so this right
over here is the world price a dollar
fifty per pound let me write it right
over there so this is our world world
price now if we assume that it's opened
up to this world price what will happen
well at the world plot price the
consumers in this market the people who
are using the sugar well they're going
to use a lot more at a dollar 50 the
place where that intersects the demand
curve is out here so now what is the
consumer surplus in this country in this
market
well the consumer surplus in this
country is now much larger it contains a
triangle that it contained before and
then all of this area that I am now
shading in and that has come at the cost
of the producer surplus the producers in
this country there are in this market
they are now only getting that producer
surplus right over there but if you look
at the total economic surplus it has
definitely grown the total economic
surplus instead of just being that
original triangle it has now extended to
include this entire area that goes all
the way out there and you can see that
that completely contains the previous
total economic surplus which we had
right over here so theoretically when a
market opens up to the world price like
this it's going to increase your total
economic surplus and if that world price
is below the equilibrium price in your
isolated economy then it's probably
going to be to the benefit of the
consumers but the producers are going to
lose out on some of their surplus now
let's say that a government comes into
power and in this market and says hey I
I've been elected by the sugar producers
of this country I don't like this go
this thing going on are sugar producers
in our country are getting hurt a lot
and they're a big voting bloc so I am
going to enact a tariff and once again a
tariff is a per unit charge or it's
oftentimes a per unit charge and let's
say that the tariff is 50 cents 50 cents
per pound per pound on imported sugar
well then what is the world price going
to look like to the market that we're
talking about well then for the
consumers in this market instead of
being able to get the world price at a
dollar 50 they would have to pay 50
cents per pound higher than that so the
tariff would make the price go over here
so in that situation what has just
happened well now where we intersect the
demand curve is a lower quantity than
when we use the world price at the world
price we
were consuming a lot of sugar in this
market now we're going to consume a
little bit less sugar but since even
with the tariffs our price is still
lower than our previous equilibrium
price when we were operating in
isolation we're still consuming more
sugar using more sugar demanding more
sugar in this market than we were when
we did not have it opened up to trade
now what did this tariff do to the
surpluses well the consumer surplus has
now gone down relative to the free trade
scenario we've lost this area down here
so now the consumer surplus I will shade
it in this blue color and we have
increased the domestic producer surplus
it has increased to this right over here
but what about this region that we seem
that seems to no longer be there either
in the consumer or the producer surplus
well some of it is the government
revenue what's the government revenue
going to be well it's going to be the
amount of the tariff times the quantity
so the amount of the tariff is going to
be that 50 cents so that's that height
right over there and then what's the
quantity that they're getting that
tariff on well this whole section right
over here is the imported quantity this
section right over here is the domestic
production and this is the imported
quantity so the imported quantity times
the tariff so this area right over here
that is going to be government revenue
but you do have some of that total
economic surplus that is just becomes
deadweight loss now you have this region
right over here
that is now deadweight loss and this
region right over here that is a
deadweight loss so I'll leave you there
as you can see here that when you open
up to trade theoretically it increases
the total economic surplus but that
could have consequences on the producers
and actually there's cases where can
have consequences on the users of
whatever or the people who are the
buyers in this market and many times a
government will enact a tariff now you
can see that that tariff will reduce the
total economic surplus some of that will
go
towards revenue while other parts of it
will just be dead weight loss another
idea that a government might sometimes
do is an idea of a quota where they're
saying hey we just don't like the total
amount of imports that are happening so
they might just put a cap on it
I'll let you think about how you might
deal with a quota and how that might
also affect the economic surplus